(upbeat music)
- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
I think we're about to enter
what will be considered
the golden age of biology,
where not only do we understand
or are starting understand
the genetic basis of things,
but we also have the power to control it.
And if you're controlling it
then the creativity gets
to a whole other level.
So in the decades to come,
creativity and biology,
and also other areas of STEM,
like mathematics and
computing are all going to
converge to really transform
humanity as we know it.
But don't take my word for it,
I'm about to introduce
you to some close friends
who can even better draw this link
between the future of biology
and the future of creativity.
(upbeat music)
- I think it's really exciting
how biology and creativity have combined,
particularly in the area
of health and outcomes
and how do we help people with blindness?
How do we help people who are paraplegic
where we can start to read
the electrical activity
of their intended movement
and have a robot do that.
So they can gain, you
know, that activity again
and have that power in their lives again.
I think that is a classic
and beautiful example
of the combination of
biology and creativity
making our lives better every single day
- Butterflies use something
called structural color
which involves bending
light to generate color
instead of using a bunch of pigment.
So it definitely saves the
butterflies a bunch of energy
in making that pigment.
But now, because of some observant
and innovative scientists,
it's saving us energy too.
It's being used in
screens around the world
to make them more efficient
at projecting color,
which reduces the carbon footprint
as some of our most common electronics.
And how about the
creativity of using mRNA,
which is pretty much just
biological text messages
to give our bodies a heads up
that they need to recognize
dangerous viruses.
It's the technology being used
in some of our most
innovative vaccines right now.
(upbeat music)
- I think it's going to
be even more important
to have the widest range of
skill sets that you could have.
So less specialization,
more a jack of all trades,
including design, design
thinking, design work,
together with that programming experience.
So that you can jump into the
new technological advances
that are being made every day.
We're gonna be so much
more in virtual reality,
can you not just use it,
but can you program it?
- I think the most important
ones will be curiosity
and keen eyed to observational skills.
See, curiosity fuels the question why
which is an essential
part of every innovation,
and keen observational skills allow us
not to waste our efforts
reinventing the wheel.
Life has already solved so
many of the toughest problems
that the world can possibly throw at it.
So why not figure out how
biology has overcome an obstacle
and adapt or improve on that?
(upbeat music)
I'd encourage every single
one of you to spend some time
immersed in a different culture
or maybe even spend some time working
in a totally different part of the world
from where you grew up.
Now, it doesn't have to
be quite that drastic.
It could be as simple as
investing in relationships
with people from other parts of the world.
And while you're at it,
I'd encourage you to learn
a different language.
Both of those experiences, I think,
will stretch your mind in ways
that help you consider
other possibilities.
- Students can expand their creative
and scientific skill sets
by thinking beyond the classroom
and beyond the textbook,
using that information from
classroom and from the textbook
and from other formal information sources
and expanding that to learn
more about both today's world
and the world that you
imagine for the future.
That involves using those
skills such as communication
and problem solving and critical thinking
to wonder not just about
what is already known,
but to wonder about what is not yet known,
which involves using creativity
to think and to wonder.
And that also means
communicating with other people
to see how they wanna
shape the world as well.
(upbeat music)
- We have the opportunity to work together
with a variety of different voices,
colleagues from all over the world
who have different
strengths that they bring,
different perspectives
that they bring about life
and about how the world operates.
And only when we bring
those voices together,
will we have a more complete picture
about how the living world works.
So in order to really solve
the problems of the future,
we're going to need to work
together as a global community
- Problems are not solved in isolation,
they're solved in collaborative
groups with other people
and they're solved to be realistic.
So you have to consider not
just your own discipline
or your own science, but also
some economics and ethics
and other things that
relate to the real world,
to help you reach a real
world, but sensible solution.
So it requires combining
all those different ways of thinking,
being communicative and problem solving
and working with other people
so that you can reach solutions
that actually benefit the world.
Because some solutions are
gonna be great on paper,
but in practice, they
aren't really practical.
So that's why using new ways
of thinking to solve problems
is really important.
- As an example, for
me, in my PhD project,
even though my background
has been in biology,
the problem that really
captured my interests
and that I wanted to pursue
involves mechanics and physics.
And so it required learning
a lot of some deep theories
and ideas in physics that I
wouldn't have thought of before.
And now I kind approach,
it sort of changed the way that I approach
biological problems.
Now I have this physics lens
that I didn't have before,
and that expands the of
experiments I can think of
or hypotheses that I could
have for how something works.
(upbeat music)
- What are those biological solutions
that can be solved with creativity
that would change the world?
And I always go to those
health, biological changes.
The cure for cancer,
the cure for blindness,
the cure for name, Alzheimer's
disease, for example.
The modulation of our crops
that would allow us to
feed the world, everybody,
so there's no starvation.
That is the goal that
all of our creativity,
kind of taken together, is headed towards.
I think that's inspiring,
I think that is doable,
and with all the tools that
we've been talking about,
technology, storytelling, and inspiration,
all of that together is
going to get us there.
- A creative approach to biology
can help solve the problems of the future.
I mean, if you think
about natural systems,
they don't have any waste,
they recycle everything.
Everything that goes into a natural system
is used completely.
And there are a lot of areas
in which we can learn from that
as people and the systems
that we create and design.
So if we can design ways to
more efficiently use water,
recycle and reduce the
amount of waste we produce,
that's gonna be one of the
most important innovations
of the future, right?
Providing fresh and clean water
to a growing population for this world.
- New innovations that I
think will help us approach
science creatively in the future,
really involve data
such as machine learning
and artificial intelligence,
and using data to help humans
make decisions collaboratively
with either other humans,
but also with artificial intelligence.
There's so much data
that exists in the world,
collected from scientific
and engineering observations,
that we can take this information
to help us make better
decisions in the future.
Because it's gonna be a
combination of people thinking
but also machines thinking,
and that can help us make
more powerful conclusions.